the libs are getting results
at the G20 Summit plow Schwab for some
reason the head of the world economic
forum for some reason is speaking
alongside the world leaders of the 20
most powerful Nations on Earth Clash fob
came out he said we are going to
transform the world
if you look at all the challenges we can
speak about the multi-crisis
economic political social and ecological
and institutional crisis
but actually
what we have to confront
is a deep systemic and structural
restructuring
of our world
and this will take some time
and the world will look differently
after
we have cons sources transition process
politically the driving forces forces
political transformation
of course
is the transition into a multi-polar
world
which has a tendency
to make our world much more fragmented
there you have it the transition into a
multi-polar world
when they talk about the great reset
when they talk about the world economic
forum's agenda
what they are talking about in the
bluntest terms is the end of American
hegemony
the fact that he's even standing up
there I love the way and what we've been
doing the future is if we will get rid
of all of your food and you will eat all
of the bugs and you will live in your
little ponds and you will not have your
countries anymore
um excuse me excuse me excuse me Mr
Schwab who are you who what like why are
you there who who elected you what I am
you feel
uh sir
I just want who are you why are you
doing this but he is right
listen just because the guy has bad
ideas
just because the guy is prescribing bad
things for the world doesn't mean that
what he is describing is inaccurate very
often people have terrible ideas about
how to move forward in in to the Future
are pretty perceptive about describing
the present Karl Marx for that matter
was pretty pretty good about his
perception of the flaws of the
capitalism of his age
as prescriptions were horrible but Clash
Rob is recognizing this that there is a
movement away from American hegemony
into a multi-polar world that is in many
ways what the mega movement is about
Maga means make America great again it's
not reduce taxes again or make us
totally free individuals again or do
whatever you want again or whatever it's
not it's make America great National
greatness
which is a push against this multi-polar
world of America does not have any power
anymore you know that's that's the the
big fight here okay
and that Trump channeling Ronald
Reagan's campaign line has has really
repopularized this idea of American
greatness now do Americans really want
to be the global hegemon anymore that
remains to be seen on the left and the
right but that is what the battle is
going to be about and we're up against
some pretty serious people you know the
rest of the show is going to continue
now when we talk about a story that
really has fascinated me the FTX
collapse this is the second largest
crypto Exchange in the world it was run
by the second largest donor to the
Democrat Party during the midterm
elections and it's this guy who prattles
on and on and on about what a wonderful
guy he has Sam freed and uh he he's he's
this uh sort of holier than now lib this
preening virtue signaler and it turns
out he's one of the biggest scam artists
of the century the whole thing collapsed
I don't know anything about crypto so
I'm interviewing Eric Voorhees who is
who is one of the OG is truly one of the
experts and leaders in the whole Space
we've got that coming up on the member
block if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]